welcome to this video look homies la
camisa and I know oh it's tricky with
the pronunciation if you already have a
non English name try to give it this
kind of English pronunciation flavor and
that done by a German cans out vary
widely ok we have got a king's indian
here going for ok matrons post to the
maraca see point don't mind that one one
of my favorite opening lines for white
never lost the tournament game with it
and won a ton but ok it's not like it's
a bad opening form for black ok when to
a five-year very very early hmm that's
interesting if I go b3 he will play a
four probably but if I have before
actually on the other hand b3 is
weakening the long diagonal quite
substantially that tactic probably not
don't see one okay now he's regrouping
97-95 and I guess if he goes Knight c5 i
have f 3 f five this kind of thing mmm i
wonder if rook be one is right it's the
normal move putting it out of the
diagonal hmm
I don't know if I go route be one night
c 5 f 3 f five if this is kind of
awkward to have the rukon be one okay I
spent some time yet but to be honest I
think this was decently spend time
because we get exactly what I had them
anticipated and now my rookie is better
on c1 because I can play more like 90
form which I will play hmm yeah we now
get those trades on deform we can also
retreat to the seven but my Ruca song
better on c1 now then on b1 okay here i
can i can take but i'm not sure about
that let's put something on even this is
this f5 break that that here went for
this some very active way for black to
play but it leaves some weaknesses
behind on the dnd file yeah the d6 d7
porn formation it's a is a weakness that
can sometimes be used um okay he's
trying to avoid those trades here hmm
okay it's f1 f1 lagi for ya I can't
let's put it here and go from there on
a4ai still have before I wonder if if i
should go fish of age six here in this
kind of position probably I should but I
can prepare this a little bit better so
let's do it Bishop h6
this Bishop is a good piece on g7 yeah
actually King h1 was a and blundered at
London 93 m okay this Bishop on on g7
lamb I after Queen e8 King edge one
wasn't really necessary so it I could
have played this this also immediately
okay so yeah that's not good blundering
into this the simple fork after black
was already in serious positional
trouble ok there are 95 this is just a
sick son Jimmy might be six then maybe
but i recreated it's not leading to very
much case taking taking first okay it's
going a 5v5 maybe for you form now that
before i can take there is no Queen f1
twin f2 however is possible so I'm going
to cover that at least I will have a
nice-looking knight on d5
yeah I was a stupid blonde named of them
of the exchange mean I really think that
this wasn't a particularly great
position for black this some this f5 is
a very very risky business it's normally
leaving too many weaknesses behind you
have some temporary activity but my
experience is that it is normally not
enough to compensate okay rook takes
rook c8 is coming politics and then 94
may be at least as a knight damn ke VI
is Queen f4 maybe with Queen age three
wow this is this is a lost position
anyway but I have to and I can of course
on phi don Queen f4 maybe but ok this
blunders d6 so he has to ok now g5 is a
move actually 95 maybe you gave 797 and
yes but now i have i have the time to
play time morning another desrook f5 but
if we can play this one maybe this one
add some self [ __ ] gotten the g5 night
it is a self pin Jim ok wasn't really
sure that he had to do something that
reticle ok
the moment I have failed to see the
point maybe he wants to just play Queen
e5 Queen g7 but that's not helping him
that much ok for I for look at four
maybe that's possible
after
ok
cheer 17 seconds the position I it's
probably still lost but I'm i don't know
i think it was worse in earlier okay can
play look everyone i have no I have no
breakthrough I can't even have root da
def idea but it's just failing okay yeah
white forfeits on time nothing to do
yeah the blunt is simply run during the
exchange here yeah okay well as
mentioned i think that this is a pretty
bad position for black he's just
suffering from those weaknesses what
what should i do actually okay I can't
play something like rook cd1 and then
bishop age six or just put put the night
out there hmm jo that's it's good yeah
drop d one was also okay I guess and
then and then play the bishop out just
not Glenn during the exchange yeah it's
also intense night to be six ok well the
computer is on like plus one which seems
kind of fair the the weakness of CR
really substantial it's difficult for
black to him to to to play around them
very difficult but okay this is just
just blundering I was just not thinking
about any tactics and after that of
course I'm struggling I mean not quite
sure that this was necessary but
probably it it is winning it's very
difficult here to do anything
yeah look f1 now what's the easy way but
we didn't do that rook see one lets me
hang on a little bit yeah maybe I ki had
to do something with a couple of seconds
on the clock yeah this is just about
working for one temple but it is working
Jeff I have this but check obviously he
is promoting so this is a loss yeah
blundering the exchange does not help
okay thanks a lot for watching